[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de Paf
consacré à l'histoire et
particulièrement au 30 ans du
laboratoire d'histoire de l'Université
de Versailles Saint-Quentin faites ses
30 ans on va savoir avec ses
responsables avec des historiens avec
aussi des spécialistes de littérature
qu'est-ce qu'on fait dans un laboratoire
d'histoire et puis on vous parlera aussi
des
actions qui seront menées notamment
jeudi et vendredi pour fêter ses 30 ans
alors pour en parler
Anne-Claude Ambroise du bonjour vous
êtes vous êtes professeur d'université
pour faire d'histoire et vous êtes la
responsable
la directrice oui du laboratoire c'est
bien
et vous allez nous expliquer justement
alors qu'est-ce que c'est un laboratoire
d'histoire parce que les gens se disent
qu'il y a des épouvains des choses comme
ça donc peut-être pas on verra ça tout à
l'heure
Aurélie barjolet bonjour alors vous vous
êtes pièce rapportée si je peux dire
ne vous inquiétez pas non en fait il n'y
a pas de laboratoire de littérature à
l'uviscq et c'est très bien pour moi
parce que finalement un peu comme
Monsieur Jourdain je pense que je
faisais de l'histoire culturelle sans le
savoir donc je me retrouve tout à fait
dans les axes du laboratoire je suis ce
qu'ils ont ce qu'on appelle une
réceptionnisme m'intéresse à la
récipient de la littérature donc ça
implique une approche historique et je
suis très à l'aise dans ce laboratoire
spécialiste
aux dictatures latinomé américaine et
ses mobilisations telles qu'elles se
sont mises en place à partir des années
70 en Europe et suppose que là vous
suivez d'un œil particulier
tout à fait qui fait écho
de passer et notamment parce que les
différents protagonistes du conflit
utilisent cette référence à l'histoire
et puis Clément verger bonjour
vous êtes docteur en histoire et
doctorant ça veut dire que vous préparez
votre thèse j'ai commencé une thèse j'ai
fini ma première année en ce moment
oui alors je travaille sur la
globalisation par les plantes plus
précisément les plantes transportées au
travers des grands voyages exploration
de la fin du XVIIIe siècle et en
particulier les trois voyages de James
Cook autour du monde d'accord comment
ces plantes ont changé le paysage
mondial
avec donc c'est un mélange d'une
pratique artistique mélangée à la
recherche donc j'aime bien le terme
d'artiste chercheurs comme quelque chose
un peu indivisible parce que vous êtes
vous avez une double casquette si je
peux dire vous êtes donc à historien et
vous êtes aussi artiste et artiste
photographe et
c'est à vous qu'on doit l'affiche c'est
bien ça des 30 ans de du stand
d'histoire culturel des sociétés
contemporaines puisque c'est le vrai nom
du laboratoire bravo merci et c'est bon
vous êtes allés voir
un clodo pour lui dire voilà moi je sais
faire des photos aussi comment ça se
passe il savait déjà pour l'affiche ou
pour le docteur
qui m'a contacté oui c'est vrai qu'après
voilà c'est
je communique quand même sur mon travail
les deux sont indivisibles c'est à dire
que la recherche et ma pratique
artistique sont des choses qui ne sont
pas séparables pour moi l'un ou l'autre
et donc les recherches m'amène à faire
les photos et les photos me poussent à
faire plus de recherches dans un sens
donc c'est un petit peu et alors on
parle sous le contrôle de Maximilien
petit qui est un peu caché derrière là
qui s'occupe d'un documentation c'est ça
oui
documentation mais pas seulement il mène
aussi un certain de de projets qui sont
en rapport avec la recherche et il est
toujours caché mais il faut bien
insister sur le fait que sans lui nous
ne serions pas là nous ne serions pas
grand chose d'ailleurs donc vraiment les
activités à la fin de l'émission les
activités du laboratoire lui doivent
énormément et c'est lui qui est à
l'origine de l'exposition qu'on peut
voir actuellement on aura un petit sujet
là-dessus alors il a travaillé avec nous
sur cette exposition dans cette
exposition elle elle a été montée par
des étudiants et par le RAF fauché notre
gestionnaire administrative très bien
alors on va parler justement de ce
laboratoire d'histoire et ben peut-être
pour en faire connaissance alors sur
votre site
il y a une vidéo qui explique un peu ce
qu'est le laboratoire d'histoire je vous
propose de le regarder puis on en parle
juste après
[Musique]
le CHCs le Centre d'histoire culturel
des sociétés contemporaine et le seul
laboratoire d'histoire en France qui se
soit donné pour mission exclusive la
recherche en histoire culturelle du
contemporain c'est à dire depuis le 18e
siècle
[Musique]
il existe depuis 30 ans et va donc fêter
cette année son anniversaire en
organisant un colloque qui n'est pas
simplement commémoratif mais qui a
vocation à inviter en tout cas à la
réflexion sur les enjeux et les
perspectives nouvelles pour l'histoire
culturelle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour compléter ce programme académique
nous avons imaginé de faire participer
les étudiants à ces festivités
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le CHCs vous invitons à les fêter avec
nous
[Applaudissements]
alors on va répondre à cette première
question c'est quoi un laboratoire
d'histoire
[Musique]
je pense que c'est des bureaux il y a
pas
de bureau avec une bibliothèque donc un
fond documentaire important qui témoigne
de la réalité de nos pratiques de la
réalité de la recherche en histoire qui
dont on pourrait penser que elle est bon
voilà l'histoire n'est plus à faire elle
a été faite les les choses sont posées
dans les faits et il n'y a plus
intervenir en réalité c'est c'est
complètement faux la recherche en
histoire est une dynamique perpétuelle
puisque des pistes nouvelles s'ouvrent
sans arrêt autour de l'apparition de
sources nouvelles et puis autour
également d'un questionnaire nouveau
c'est-à-dire que en histoire on se pose
des questions qui sont en lien avec le
temps dans lequel on vit avec
l'actualité voilà pas l'histoire de la
même façon aujourd'hui qu'on la voyait
il y a 50 ans et qu'on invente aussi ou
qu'on découvre je ne sais pas quel est
le terme qui convient des objets
nouveaux des objets d'histoire et j'en
prends pour exemple justement le sujet
thèse de de Clément qui témoigne du
nouveauté en histoire quelle histoire
environnementale
qui sont en train de mettre et qui sont
en face évidemment avec avec les
évolutions de la société avec les
questions nouvelles que se posent la
société alors Caroline et j'ai
omis de dire que vous étiez les les
directrices adjointe de ce de ce centre
de ce laboratoire
est-ce que c'est
cette ça existe un peu partout des
laboratoires comme ça ou c'est assez
spécifique alors le laboratoire du
Centre d'histoire culturel des sociétés
comptables telles et son nom
en fait il n'est pas déjà c'est le
deuxième laboratoire d'histoire à
l'université Versailles à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines on n'est pas
le seul mais l'autre qui s'appelle Dipac
ça veut dire quoi porte sur la période
de l'époque de l'Antiquité jusqu'à
l'époque mod
patrimoniale donc on se répartit en
quelque sorte d'un point de vue
chronologique en fait nos champs de
recherche mais c'est vrai que le on peut
pas mettre dans un même dans une même
structure des gens qui recherchent sur
le Moyen-âge et des ressources qui
recherchent l'histoire contemporaine
c'est pas c'est pas impossible mais la
logique a été différente à l'université
de versa 50 ans en Yvelines et en fait
on travaille de manière conjointe sur
certains projets et notamment autour de
des outils parce que on a évoqué les
nouveaux questionnements que l'on peut
poser sur l'histoire mais on doit aussi
s'adapter à l'apparition de nouveaux
outils et maximiser un petit pourra sans
doute revenir sur cette question puisque
à l'université Versailles à 50 ans on a
un FabLab un laboratoire qui alors là
peut-être répond plus à ce qu'on imagine
comme un laboratoire avec c'est une
salle où il y a tout un matériel qui
permet de collecter de et de valoriser
toutes les nouvelles formes de de
données et notamment numérique tout ce
qui est autour du numérique une
impression en 3D etc tout cela est
rendue possible grâce à ce FabLab qui
est justement co
gérer par Maxime appétit et son collègue
de Dipac l'autre laboratoire d'histoire
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines 30 ans
c'est pas qu'il veut répondre mais
comment tout a commencé
tout a commencé il y a 30 ans en 1992
ce laboratoire de l'université
c'est la naissance d'un laboratoire
d'histoire culturelle du contemporain
donc c'était important parce que voilà
de du contemporain dans cette jeune
université c'est université d'un
troisième type parce qu'elle était en la
seconde couronne autour de Paris et il
faut bien dire que c'est ces nouveautés
cette jeunesse correspondait à la
thématique du laboratoire parce que
l'histoire culturelle était à ce
moment-là un peu un front en histoire
pas tout à fait une nouveauté mais un
front pionnier je dirais que d'ailleurs
front pionnier elle le respect
perpétuellement parce que justement les
questions les problématiques de
l'histoire culturel se renouvelle en
permanence
pas une définition peut-être un
déclenche qu'est-ce que c'est l'histoire
culturelle alors c'est plusieurs choses
beaucoup de choses
c'est elle
œuvre des œuvres d'arts
des affiches
des médias de la presse écrite à
internet en passant par Dieu par la
télévision le cinéma la littérature
c'est aussi l'histoire des pratiques
donc l'édition le la lecture en gros
c'est une histoire qui s'articule autour
de trois données la production la
communication et la réception voilà
autour de trois de trois gestes je
dirais c'est donc une histoire qui
entretient il y a des liens étroits avec
l'histoire politique avec l'histoire
sociale parce qu'à Laurie le fondateur
du laboratoire définit oui c'est parce
que 1992
qui définit l'histoire culturelle comme
une histoire sociale des représentations
collectives de bande dessinée
de beaucoup de choses et donc c'est
cette multiplicité des objets des
terrains des pratiques je dirais aussi
une méthode parce que l'histoire
culturelle c'est aussi peut-être avant
tout d'ailleurs une façon de questionner
la réalité quotidienne des individus et
une façon qui emprunte assez largement à
l'anthropologie par exemple cette
variété donc des pratiques en histoire
culturelle
implique me semble-t-il exige presse
presque l'interdisciplinarité
c'est-à-dire la présence au sein de ce
laboratoire d'historien mais on l'a vu
avec Aurélie de
représentants de d'espaces culturel
autre Américain
germanophone etc des musicologues aussi
et donc c'est c'est ce mélange c'est
cette diversité qui assure évidemment
une communication et un dynamisme
constant des recherches que l'on peut
faire au sein de ce laboratoire
peut-être vous pouvez nous parler de la
liberté de votre présence dans vous qui
êtes
de littérature comparée
vous voulez que je vous parle de mon
rôle de directrice adjointe ou bien dans
la présence de la littérature
oui alors je ne suis pas la seule
littéraire du laboratoire nous sommes
très nombreux en littérature comparée il
y a aussi ma collègue évangéliste qui
travaille sur les revues illustrées moi
je travaille donc vous l'avez dit sur la
littérature des non témoins de la choix
et je travaille aussi sur la réception
de Zola j'ai travaillé sur la réception
de Zola comment
un petit peu Flaubert aussi mais surtout
Zola parce que Zola est très intéressant
c'est un romancier c'est un intellectuel
et on peut pas faire comme si c'était
pas existant c'est à dire que parfois
quand on dit quelque chose sur Zola on
dit à la fois quelque chose sur le
romancier mais aussi sur le défenseur de
Dreyfus et la question elle est très
intéressante quand on regarde
l'Allemagne d'après 45 notamment moi
j'ai regardé la RFA la RDA donc la RDA
qui tout de suite évidemment
de Zola du défenseur de Dreyfus en mode
nous sommes la bonne Allemagne
antifasciste et puis la RFA qui a un
petit peu peur de toucher ces questions
politiques et qui ne s'intéressent pas à
Zola dans un premier temps puis arrive
mes 68 et là on redécouvre Zola et de
savoir comment il est il est apprécié
le rapport de la France là mais c'est
vrai que c'est très intéressant de
savoir et ah oui ça c'est parce que de
savoir que la RDA est la femme n'avait
pas du tout le même tout à fait et puis
bon j'ai eu la chance
l'Allemagne peut-être aussi elle n'est
pas pour rien dans l'affaire dreyfusion
oui bien sûr bien sûr
[Musique]
moi ce que j'ai surtout remarqué c'est
que c'est un auteur qui qui n'est pas
marxiste mais qui a assez proche de la
gauche et que donc il pose un vrai une
vraie question
aux Allemands qui sont là enfin c'est le
pays où de naissance de la sociale
démocratie donc si vous voulez une
certaine logique à regarder ce qui se
passe dans la réception Zola dans ce
pays-là et j'ai eu la chance de
rencontrer un petit peu vous voyez c'est
un petit ça ressemble aussi au travail
de l'historien de rencontrer des témoins
de l'époque des gens qui avaient connu
la RDA qui avait essayé de promouvoir
Zola en RDA et de voir avec eux quels
problèmes ils avaient rencontré s'ils
avaient eu des injonctions du régime etc
donc ça ça a été vraiment intéressant
pour moi donc je vous dis comme je vous
disais tout à l'heure c'était déjà
l'histoire orale mais je n'avais pas
forcément conscience c'était mes
premiers pas dans la recherche
et en même temps des des frontières très
faibles très très mince
peut-être Caroline moine puisqu'on parle
d'histoire culturelle
à la chercheuse et intellectuelle ou pas
pour résumer pour le pour les gens qui
connaissent pas en histoire au fond on a
on a beaucoup de de de qualificatif
culturelle mais ça peut être quoi
l'histoire événementiel je sais pas
enfin ah oui oui on a beaucoup d'écoles
ou de tiroirs
selon le regard qu'on porte sur ces
caractérisations des différentes
manières de faire l'histoire et c'est
vrai comme le disait Anne-Claude
l'histoire culturelle et aussi née d'une
volonté de sortir de ses définitions
telles qu'elles existaient et de
proposer une autre manière de travailler
et aujourd'hui on peut être aussi de
prédisposition des enseignants qui sont
là aussi non de c'est lié aux envies au
centre d'intérêt
l'histoire est faite par des individus
donc les acteurs sont fondamentaux
après l'autre des gens Yves Molier
spécialiste de l'édition Christian
Delporte spécialiste des médias
Anne-Claude rendus maintenant qui
travaille aussi justement sur des
questions environnementales donc
évidemment le nos centres d'intérêt
influencent fortement la manière dont on
a on souhaite faire l'histoire mais ceci
c'est le cadre collectif qui qui joue
beaucoup et c'est là que joue aussi du
coup le le l'échelle d'un laboratoire on
est dans un airbor on est une équipe
alors il y a des axes des sous-groupes
mais on travaille on est amené à
travailler à échanger ensemble autour de
d'ateliers de journées d'études de
colloque mais aussi on est un centre où
on forme on est tous enseignants
après peut-être de chacun de vos
recherches personnelles mais est-ce que
dans l'enseignement
aussi enfin la dimension culturelle de
l'histoire est importante ou est-ce que
vous évadez de ça pour enseigner je sais
pas au 1er année d'histoire au deuxième
des histoires
les deux les deux c'est effectivement
de socle
auprès d'étudiants qui arrivent ne
savent pas forcément grand-chose et puis
enfin des la deuxième année il y a une
spécialité d'histoire culturelle il y a
un parcours et nos Masters sont des
masters recherche en histoire culturelle
des 19e des 20e 20e et 21e siècle mais
quand on passe le capetation il y a
une discipline il y a une matière
d'histoire culturelles c'est des
questions qui peuvent relever de
l'histoire culturelles selon les années
du concours il y a des programmes oui
c'est ça justement alors Clément verger
on peut être au fond historien et
acteurs de
culturel oui
c'est un petit peu compliqué disons que
j'offre une réflexion je pense c'est
plus en tout cas si on parle de la forme
des expositions
ces données au public
une autre perspective sur les mêmes
sujets au final et aussi un espace de
réflexion sur ces questions là c'est pas
forcément apporter des réponses ou des
solutions mais en tout cas c'est aussi
donner de l'information et d'une autre
manière en fait moi c'est ça qui
m'intéresse aussi dans ce laboratoire
dans ces pratiques c'est ce qu'on n'a
pas de répéter mais le côté
pluridisciplinaire qui apporte une
richesse en fait de mélange des
différentes perspectives et cette
ouverture c'est la dernière année des
sciences et des arts qui dialogue de
plus en plus
assez nouveau en France existe depuis
plus longtemps dans les mondes angles
sanctions en tout cas le type de docteur
que je fais moi qu'un doctorat par le
projet
c'est un modèle qui est un peu plus
ancien en Angleterre au Canada aux
États-Unis mais qui commence vraiment à
se développer en France et apporte ça en
fait c'est à dire que en fait tout le
monde s'y retrouve il y a une vraie
richesse en fait à dialoguer et apporter
différentes pointes perspective sur les
mêmes sujets en fait
alors on va parler si vous voulez bien
aussi parce qu'il y a un des événements
il y a l'exposition on en parle tout à
l'heure mais il y a aussi le colloque
qui a lieu à l'occasion de ces 30 ans
vous allez nous raconter ce que c'est
que ce colloque des 30 ans
[Musique]
alors il y a
un thème qui est important c'est les
nouveaux territoires de l'histoire
culturelle
oui
l'objectif de cette première table ronde
du colloque c'est donc de de présenter
puis de réfléchir aussi sur les les
travaux novateurs qui ont été menés en
histoire culturelles au sein du
laboratoire
depuis ces dernières années alors
évidemment ces travaux ont posé un
certain nombre de questions de questions
un peu nouvelles
autour de
l'americanisation le métissage par
exemple les circulations et évidemment
toujours quand même les héritages
culturels mais peut-être Aurélie tu veux
compléter oui on a on a prévu cette
première table ronde autour de des
circulations transatlantiques avec des
spécialistes de ce qu'on appelle les
civilisations des États-Unis mais aussi
des études la américaine aussi en
anglais et en musicologie et un deuxième
temps autour des enjeux culturels au
cœur des relations internationales avec
là aussi des interventions de
professeurs mais aussi de doctorants ou
de jeunes docteurs ça nous tenait
beaucoup à cœur d'avoir cette
représentativité dans chaque tableau au
monde et c'est réservé aux historiens ou
c'est ouvert au public on peut venir
au public on va essayer de parler de
manière audible et intelligible pour
pour tous ça se tient à l'université
la deuxième thématique de cette table
ronde autour de des enjeux culturels
dans les relations internationales
boucle d'une certaine manière avec des
questions qui sont des questions
d'actualité autour de l'Ukraine par
exemple c'est
il faut toujours se dire voilà
la possibilité de la diplomatie
culturelle et aussi la première table
ronde insiste sur le fait que au
laboratoire on travaille vraiment sur
des espaces très différents et on se on
se répartit un petit peu nos recherches
d'un point de vue thématique les objets
de recherche mais aussi les espaces et
on a vraiment beaucoup de chercheuses et
de chercheurs qui travaillent sur cet
espace transatlantique avec notamment un
projet collectif porté par un is Fléchet
sur le dictionnaire des cultures
atlantiques c'est transatlantic culture
c'est un dictionnaire en ligne et où se
retrouve d'historienne historien
littéraire civilisation
spécialiste histoire de l'art etc et qui
retrace l'histoire des relations entre
les en Europe les Amériques et l'Afrique
puisqu'on a aussi donc des spécialistes
d'Afrique comme François robinet qui a
travaillé sur le qui travaille sur le
génocide
et parmi nos partenariats on a
l'université chez Kanté Diop de Dakar
université de Sao Paulo au Brésil etc
donc c'est aussi cette cette dimension
là qui est soulignée dans cette dans la
première table ronde et parler
des tables ronds de nouvelles écritures
de l'histoire culturelle ça veut dire
quoi
ça veut dire que l'histoire culturelle
se fait aujourd'hui à partir de nouveaux
de nouveaux instruments de recherche qui
nécessairement induisent de nouvelles
façons d'écrire je pense que dans le
monde des médias on
mesure très bien cette nouveauté
il y a une table ronde aussi consacrée à
l'histoire face au patrimoine
oui alors ça c'est un des axes qui a été
développé depuis quelques années un des
axes un peu nouveau du laboratoire et
dans la nouveauté est accrue par
l'intégration dans la notion de
patrimoine du patrimoine naturel
c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui nous
travaillons alors oui on peut dire comme
ça pas tout à fait ça mais on peut dire
comme ça mais absolument donc ce qui
nous amène à travailler à la fois sur
les politiques culturelles qui ont
présidé à la patrimonialisation les
monuments etc et puis également
évidemment au
motif qui préside à cette
patrimonialisation c'est à dire quand on
crée un patrimoine qui soit culturel ou
naturel qu'est-ce qu'on veut protéger
qu'est-ce qu'on veut préserver qu'est-ce
qu'on comment on trie et qu'est-ce
qu'elle est l'objet quel est le critère
de choix qu'a présidé à la sélection de
cet objet là pourquoi celui-ci est pas
un autre pourquoi cet espace naturel
mérite d'être protégé et pas qui est
juste à côté et qu'est-ce que ça a comme
conséquence de protéger là et pas là et
c'est vrai que oui alors il y a les
patrimoine naturelle mais quand on parle
des des ce qui est retenu comme
patrimoine par le Nesco par exemple
c'est aussi des pratiques culturelles je
pense pas celle-là bien sûr
un séminaire sur la gastronomie il y a
beaucoup de recherches sur la sur les
gastronomie
les médias et la médiatisation de la
gastronomie au sein du laboratoire et
puis il y aura une table ronde qui sera
aussi consacrée aux 30 ans
qui reviennent sur leur propre histoire
c'est leur réalité de la première soirée
puisque Anne-Claude va s'entretenir avec
ses prédécesseurs et revenir justement
sur cette histoire du laboratoire et sur
les différentes étapes les différents
moments vécus par notre laboratoire
différents thèmes mais aussi les
différentes collaborations de notre
laboratoire avec Claude étant la
première directrice du laboratoire
moi ça me va tout à fait bien sûr
est-ce que est-ce que alors segment ce
féminisme un peu je suppose d'une façon
générale mais on parle toujours des
historiens mais aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il
y a en majorité plus d'historienne que
d'historiens de je sais pas l'université
ou c'est à peu près on sait pas de
statistiques de fête mais enfin en tout
cas je les connais pas je connais pas
les chiffres mais à l'échelle de notre
laboratoire on peut dire que la
répartition est tout à fait voilà
équilibrée
alors dans les cours il y a beaucoup
plus de femmes que d'hommes mais ça
change ça dépend aussi mais il y a quand
même toujours plus de femmes
donc vous êtes un peu seul
non mais ça dépend aussi des études
là-dessus pourquoi pourquoi
il y a plus d'hommes en histoire
économique et il y a plus de femmes en
histoire culturelles d'accord mais ça
c'est on voit bien que le racinement
culturel de ce choix là bien entendu
et alors il y aura aussi le cœur des
étudiants du Master muscologie de
l'université d'Évry Val de Somme qui
viendra faire un concert c'est ça
le jeudi soir puisque le rasthme donc le
laboratoire de musicologie de cet
université a rejoint le chcsc récemment
et nous nous sommes dit que pour donner
un caractère un peu plus festif à ces
cet anniversaire parce que c'est quand
même une fête d'anniversaire il serait
bien de les associer de cette manière-là
et de les entendre chanter ce sera un
moment de grâce dans cet université qui
n'est pas forcément toujours très très
régulièrement ouverte disons à
l'activité artistique et justement la
musicologie c'est de la musique ou de
l'histoire
les deux
concrètement par exemple
interviendra Philippe komplovic qui lui
a travaillé dans le cadre avec nous
avant d'être intégré au laboratoire on
avait un projet sur l'opéra de Beethoven
Fidelio et nous avons travaillé ensemble
sur l'histoire de cette opéra née déjà
de transfert entre la France et
l'Allemagne jusqu'à ses différentes mise
en scène y compris à l'occasion de la
libération de Mandela en Afrique du Sud
etc donc on retrouve les trois moments
qu'évoqués Anne-Claude en histoire
culturelle comment un opéra est né est
écrit et les différentes mises en scène
et les différents types de réception et
donc là on a travaillé avec un
musicologue avec qui a davantage
travaillé sur la partition sur les
enjeux justement d'un interprétation des
des chanteurs chanteuses etc et puis
nous historiens historienne on était
sensible au contexte justement à des
enjeux de traduction etc par exemple
comment Fidelio a été utilisé dans
l'occasion la plupart de réouverture des
opéras en Europe après 1945 et c'était
un dialogue extrêmement intéressant moi
j'ai appris beaucoup
pourquoi
Fidelio parce que c'était Beethoven
reste une figure un compositeur
qui convient à peu près à tout le monde
et Fidelio finit par un message d'espoir
et de libération alors il a pu être
utilisé aussi bien par les nazis que à
la libération par les Soviétiques que
par les Américains et c'est ça qui est
intéressant justement de voir la
complexité de cet objet et de cette
lecture et là donc on était vraiment en
dialogue avec chacun nos outils nos
langages notre langage respectif mais ça
donnait lieu à des échanges extrêmement
intéressants
je sais pas vous le connaissez peut-être
mais le nouveau doyen de la Faculté de
Droit est un historien du droit est un
spécialiste de l'Opéra si vous avez
voulu et il a fait sa thèse je crois sur
le théâtre Paris et en plus il est fou
de peur donc voilà
donc voilà donc ce colloque voilà ça va
être passionnant pendant avec beaucoup
d'interventions de de de
gens de l'université qui viennent
d'ailleurs et d'ailleurs aussi nous
avons invité des gens venant d'ailleurs
justement et comme le colloque est
organisé autour de table ronde il sera
sans doute plus intéressant à suivre que
je un colloque un peu plus académique et
traditionnel parce que parce que voilà
il s'agira d'écouter des conversations
absolument plus que des interventions
plus académiques
la grande accélération qui qu'est-ce que
c'est la danse d'accélération justement
une oeuvre une oeuvre une installation
c'est une installation qui la grande
accélération en fait c'est la grande
accélération de la fonte des glaces donc
on est vraiment là dans un sujet très
paradoxalement brûlant et donc et le
Xavier aubois a accompagné donc avec le
soutien de d'un collègue aussi de l'USQ
à travailler sur la mise en musique
sonore et nouvelles de ce processus de
la fonte des glaces d'où le nom de la
grande accélération vous inviter à venir
voir
s'immerger dans cette installation qui
qui sera
qui pourrait qui sera visible de
mercredi à vendredi oui
on pourra aussi voir des capsules
poétiques d'Armel schitrique qui est une
chercheuse associée à notre laboratoire
et on pourra aussi voir d'autres
oui il y a la station d'écoute il y a
les podcasts parce que nous avons nous
nous sommes lancés dans la réalisation
de podcasts en histoire culturel pour
justement faire connaître la diversité
de nos objets donc il y a déjà certains
épisodes disponibles les gens pourront
venir les écouter sur place donc c'est
véritablement ouvert au grand public et
justement pour continuer à parler de du
programme de notre coloc la deuxième
journée s'ouvre avec une table ronde à
destination du public puisque nous
allons proposer la question de la
démocratisation des savoirs
universitaires alors comment nous les
chercheurs on peut encore mieux toucher
le grand public mais on va aussi avoir
des intervenants comme le musée de la
ville ou bien le château de Versailles
et voir avec eux comment
notamment Internet modifie la relation
qu'ils peuvent avoir au public parce
qu'il y a pas que la réception des
publics ça vous arrive de d'être
justement sollicité par le musée de la
ville par le château de Versailles enfin
des institutions comme ça pour
participer à des comment monte une
exposition Comment enfin on parle
justement au grand public oui à cette
dimension là bien sûr mais pas seulement
on se délocalise parfois au château pour
des séminaires on a la chance de d'avoir
des partenaires là-bas et en Claude fait
un séminaire justement sur
l'appropriation de de cette des
questions autour de du château de
Versailles au 19e siècle
là aussi des collaborations avec le
Théâtre de la Ville Caroline tu es plus
au courant que moi là-dessus c'est vrai
que il y a quelques années il y avait eu
une série de table ronde qui était
organisé par nos étudiants de Master
d'accord avec le Théâtre de la Ville et
c'est tableau rondes il y en avait eu
une par exemple sur les cours de les
migrants
et c'est un partenariat que l'on va
reprendre
où on est vraiment là exactement sur le
nos enjeux qui est celle de qui les
enjeux de diffuser les résultats de nos
recherches et nous aussi on apprend
énormément évidemment à dialoguer avec
le public avec des professionnels
d'autres domaines que le monde
universitaire
d'être une tour d'ivoire enfin on disait
ça
les choses ont beaucoup changé oui les
choses ont beaucoup changé et notamment
sous l'impulsion de l'histoire culturel
qui nous oblige en quelque sorte à
dialoguer avec les acteurs de la vie
culturelle des politiques culturelles
mais aussi avec des praticiens de la
culture alors on va voilà donc on a dit
à peu près ce qui était le laboratoire
ce qui allait se passer dans les jours
qui viennent on va peut-être parler un
peu de vous si vous êtes d'accord
si vous voulez
[Musique]
commencer par vous
non ça vous ennuie
si ça m'ennuie toujours de parler de moi
mais allons-y oui non non pas parler de
vous de vos recherches de recherche
d'abord
l'émission on a un petit point commun
c'est que vous avez fait votre thèse
elle est partie sur quoi sur les faits
divers dans la presse française à la fin
du 19e siècle absolument et vous l'avez
fait votre maître de thèse
Alain Corbin qui est un historien
délicieux si je veux dire enfin que qui
a mis au point aussi une sorte
d'histoire culturelle pour le coup
qui est connu pour être le créateur de
l'histoire des sensibilités
et alors il se trouve que je l'ai connu
quand il était encore prof de lycée je
l'ai eu comme prof de lycée avant qui
invoqué l'autre à l'université donc ça
nous fait un petit un petit point commun
vous voilà donc vous avez intéressé au
fait divers et vous intéressez beaucoup
à l'histoire au fond de la violence
c'est ça oui enfin c'est dire je suis
venu à la violence par le fait divers au
départ je me suis intéressé au fait
divers en me disant tiens c'est quoi
cette rubrique de presse ça va être
rigolo de faits divers dans votre vie il
y en a toujours non mais dans votre tête
il y en a oui il y en a 16000 16000
voilà donc
il faut il faut aller voir
cet objet cet objet de presse auquel
personne ne s'est intéressée parce que
par définition c'est la rubrique des
chiens écrasés donc ça n'a pas c'est
tout à fait secondaire et Alain Corbin
était tout à fait d'accord avec moi pour
pour ce projet et donc et j'ai découvert
dans ces faits divers qu'il y avait
quand même une grosse quantité de récits
de crimes de meurtre bref de récit de
violence et donc j'ai glissé à la
violence si je peux dire les choses de
cette manière là pour m'intéresser
ensuite plus directement à des d'autres
formes par des formes de criminalité
notamment de criminalité sexuelle dont
la pédophilie dont la pédophile dans ce
que l'on appelle la pédophile et alors
c'est pas moi
une vision va très très mais aussi bien
évidemment mais j'ai alors vous avez
fait de recherche
[Musique]
le psychopathe tueur d'enfant qui est du
trou et le pédophile moyen lambda je
dirais qui n'est pas un violent et cette
discrimination elle est faite par les
psychiatres mais elle est pas faite ni
par les médias ni par le public et c'est
vrai que alors des écrivains qui étaient
reçus en grande pompe à vendre des
émissions
culturelles enfin dire formidables et
puis après ils ont été considéré comme
société qui évoluée de manière et c'est
là où on voit l'intérêt de l'histoire
culturel c'est que un discours est
produit dans un contexte de données et
il est possible que dans ce contexte
puis le contexte change et on ne peut
plus l'entendre on ne peut plus
l'accepter il y a aussi alors je sais
pas si vous avez vu tout travailler sur
ce sur ce tableau qui est intéressant
c'est aussi le thème de l'insécurité du
sentiment la sécurité oui bien sûr je
travaille là-dessus quand on travaille
un peu sur la criminalité et sur les
médias forcément
donc on rencontre l'insécurité au coin
du bois si j'ose dire et bon on peut
dire très grossièrement que le sentiment
d'insécurité quelque chose qui est
indissociable de du discours médiatique
dire c'est partir du moment où il y a
des journaux pour raconter les crimes
pour dire ce qu'il se passe dans les
rues dans les campagnes etc pour dire
quelque chose la criminalité que le
sentiment d'insécurité va enfler chez
les lecteurs de journaux et c'est normal
d'autant que cette rencontre entre le
crime et les médias elle est aussi
contemporaine d'une rencontre entre les
statistiques oui le crime et les médias
à partir du moment où on compte on parle
depuis tout temps
26 27 c'est ça donc cette rencontre
explique que on voit monter en puissance
un sentiment d'insécurité à la fin du
XIXe siècle qui depuis a connu des flux
et des reflux mais n'a jamais
complètement décrit non plus
on avait plus peur au 19e siècle
qu'aujourd'hui ou
c'est compliqué est-ce que le sentiment
de la sécurité était plus est-ce que je
veux dire peut-être aussi les grands
médias la télévision etc peut-être
accrue aussi
les grands médias de la fin du 19e
e
un million et demi pour pour certains
titres d'exemplaires qui est très lus
qui circule énormément qui est illustré
avec des dessins expressionnistes qui
montrent des crimes qui évidemment ne
peut pas filmer mais qu'on peut dessiner
donc ça c'est la force du de cette
presse là donc je sais pas si ce
sentiment d'insécurité accrue ce que ce
que je peux dire c'est qu'il a été
instrumentalisé
par le discours politique
ce fait divers qui est probablement
changer le résultat du premier coup les
hommes politiques on compr avons compris
qu'il pouvait faire quelque chose avec
ce sentiment là
on le voit toujours hein
Carole moi alors on peut parler un peu
de vous vous avez commencé à en parler
un petit peu de vous de recherche
par exemple une histoire de
mobilisations
de solidarité internationale ça c'est
aussi intéressant c'est un peu ce que
c'est effectivement c'est le voir
aujourd'hui avec peut-être avec
l'Ukraine
des mobilisations comme ça avec des
grandes causes c'était d'interroger le
le moment de mobilisation de solidaire
internationale après le coup d'État au
Chili du 11 septembre 1973 lorsque le
général Pinochet arrive au pouvoir avec
la mort de Salvador Allende le président
élu démocratiquement et qui se suicide
dans son palais bombardé par les
militaires qui font le coup d'État et
ayant travaillé comme Aurélie on est sur
l'Allemagne de l'Est auparavant ce qui
m'intéressait c'est de voir comment ce
mouvement de solidarité internationale
contre la dictature chilienne était
aussi fort en Europe de l'Est qu'en
Europe de l'Ouest et que c'était un des
moments justement qui dépassaient a
priori la division est-ouest et qui
intégré aussi donc des pays
latino-américains du Sud et donc j'ai
voulu en fait interroger ces moments-là
qui sont très présents dans les grands
récits des parties de Gauche communiste
socialistes et voir comment une
solidarité internationale ça n'arrive
pas du jour au lendemain c'est une
construction avec des personnes des
groupes qui qui font tout pour mobiliser
et toucher créer des émotions pour que
des gens tout d'un coup se sentent
concernés par ce qui se passe à des
milliers de kilomètres de chez soi
c'est-à-dire des européens se sont
concernés par ce qui se passe au Chili
etc
parce qu'il me semble je sais pas qu'on
connaît plus pédophile
on était plus mobilisés pour le ce qui
se passait au Chili que pour ce qui se
passait en Argentine qui était aussi
cruelle
a inspiré la figure de Dark Vador pour
Lucas
c'est la figure du mal et il et ça c'est
un des héritages justement de ces très
fortes mobilisation de ceintures
internationale qui passe largement aussi
par les médias par les affiches par la
musique c'est ces musiciens en exil et
autres qui récupèrent le thème du Chili
et qui du coup vraiment nourrissent la
culture populaire à l'échelle vraiment
internationale et puis aussi le cinéma
est dans les médias télévision radio
donc on a vraiment pendant parce que la
dictature dure de 73 à 90
dans toutes ces décennies on a vraiment
tout un ensemble de discours et un
imaginaire associé à la dénonciation des
des crimes commis par la gente militaire
au Chili et c'est intéressant de voir
justement comment c'est les enjeux aussi
qu'on peut se poser quand on se lance
dans une mobilisation de nos jours c'est
sur la durée sous le coup de l'émotion
après mais comment on dit les choses
passent plus peut-être nous oui mais on
le voit pour l'Ukraine cette
mobilisation qui a été très forte et là
aussi elle a été aussi très créée par le
gouvernement ukrainien qui par exemple
lance une communication une
communication très très réglée avec un
appel à la solidarité internationale
aussi à l'appel de volontaires
internationaux en faisant une référence
explicite à la guerre d'Espagne en 1936
et donc il y a vraiment une utilisation
pour créer cette émotion et pour
mobiliser et on voit l'enjeu c'est de
tenir sur la durée et de voir quels sont
les autres manières de la part de
président zelanski et de toute l'équipe
qui est autour de lui pour toucher
et aussi évidemment la contre propagande
côté russe et c'est intéressant de
évidemment de comparer avec des moments
précédents même si l'histoire ne serait
pas déjà mais et dans le cas ukrainien
voilà c'est de voir aussi comment les
Ukrainiens comme les Russes comme on le
sait aussi Poutine et son gouvernement
tentent de mobiliser ces imaginaires
passées et émouvoir aussi en faisant
référence à la grande guerre patriotique
côté russe ou à la défense justement à
la guerre d'Espagne etc côté
ukrainien donc c'est c'est là que le
regard de des chercheuses des historiens
historiennes de peuvent un peu aider à
déconstruire voilà et à prendre un petit
peu un pas de recul pour mieux
comprendre ce dans quoi on est tous
emporté par le flux comme vous le disiez
une accélération des informations des
images en continu et quelques mots
qu'est-ce que nous dit d'histoires
justement de cette guerre
la guerre en Ukraine parce qu'on a
beaucoup de choses
en effet c'était mais est-ce que c'est
des mêmes peuples est-ce qu'il y a des
régions qui sont peut-être pas tout à
fait les qui n'ont pas tout à fait on le
voit bien quand il est référendum qui
ont pas tout à fait le même relation
avec la Russie que d'autres en Ukraine
par exemple elle est spécialiste de
l'Ukraine qui sont nombreuses c'est
surtout des femmes
en français et ailleurs démontre
clairement que ce qui se déroule en ce
moment n'est pas n'est pas né en février
dernier il faut déjà remonter à Maïda en
2013 et 2014 lorsque les Ukrainiens se
révoltent contre un gouvernement
totalement
pourri et qui veulent donc ce couper
vraiment les liens très avec avec la
Russie et surtout l'influence économique
et politique plus ou moins
voulu par de Moscou sur sur l'Ukraine
donc on voit que il faut encore une fois
comprendre des mouvements qui se font de
manière très lentement sur le temps long
et ce qui montre aussi ce qui se passe
c'est que les médias n'ont pas voulu
voir ce qui se passait depuis 2014 et
par exemple loubureau qui a réalisé ce
documentaire que je vous conseille de
voir les tranchées il a tourné en 2020
sur ce front qui était comme les
tranchées de 14-18 à l'est de l'Ukraine
ou en fait il ne se passait rien
puisqu'il y avait les Russes d'un côté
ou les enfin plutôt les ceux qui étaient
prorus d'un côté et puis ce qui était
opposé
Ukrainiens opposés à l'alliance russe il
se faisait face dans leur tranchées et
il a il est journaliste les médias ne
voulaient rien entendre et tout d'un
coup là depuis février on lui demande
d'aller sur le terrain en lui réclame
plein de projets plein de sujets etc et
il le dit il le répète si on avait voulu
voir si on avait écouté notamment les
journalistes qui étaient sur le terrain
ou les experts les spécialistes
peut-être que les choses se serait passé
un peu différemment donc c'est aussi une
leçon sur sur le rôle des médias et sur
voilà sur la manière ou non de couvrir
les événements et de voir ou ne pas voir
ce qui se déroule sous nos yeux
c'était sur un festival de cinéma en
Allemagne de l'Est vous êtes bilingue
je comprends très bien on comprend que
je suis française quand je parle
allemand mais je me fais comprendre
Aurélie alors on a un petit peu parlé de
recherche aujourd'hui
quand on décide comme ça vous le faites
seul vous faites avec des étudiants il y
a aussi des étudiants qui participent
l'habilitation c'est seul après mais
j'ai la chance d'échanger avec votre
tête c'était sur la réception de Zola
dans les cercles de gauche en France et
en Allemagne
là vraiment je l'ai fait seul
j'enseignais pas encore par contre le
sujet de la deuxième thèse c'était la
littérature des noms témoins de ce que
j'appelle les petits enfants de la Shoah
et là j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir au
niveau master avoir quelques séminaires
ce sujet donc de d'en parler avec les
étudiants et puis quand on retravaille
son sa thèse pour publication on pense
beaucoup aux étudiants et ça ça m'a
beaucoup aidé pour pour tout reprendre
et pour faire un livre pour le grand
public les noms que vous dites-moi c'est
donc les les
credo exprès je fais exprès parce qu'on
parle beaucoup des témoins les témoins
de la Shoah malheureusement
disparaissent et il y a une double
urgence aussi à la fois recueillir leurs
paroles mais il y a aussi faire vivre
une mémoire familiale qui est en train
de disparaître on sait que l'histoire se
raconte dans les familles sur trois
quatre générations on a rencontré nos
grands-parents peut-être comme c'est mon
cas mes arrières grands-parents et après
c'est fini je parle de la circulation de
l'histoire dans les familles on a
beaucoup dit sur enfin sous les drames
de la Deuxième Guerre mondiale il veut
beaucoup de non-dits de la part de gens
qui ont
qui ont survécu
j'ai beaucoup regardé ce qui se passait
en Allemagne et en France il y a une
étude très célèbre en Allemagne qui
s'appelle grand-père n'était pas en Asie
c'est un
psychosociologue qui s'appelle AAL
welcer qui est allé interroger pas
seulement les témoins de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale qui était sympathisants
mais aussi leur famille et ils montrent
que souvent
les témoins ont raconté un récit assez
subjectif et partiellement lacunaire que
la deuxième génération les enfants n'ont
pas cherché vraiment à en savoir
beaucoup plus et puis les petits enfants
allemands qui sont nés à l'époints qui
ont vécu le devoir de mémoire à l'école
sont très curieux et ont surtout très
envie que leur famille ait été du bon
côté donc parfois il réécrivent
l'histoire dans un sens positif et
ravalcaire explique qu'il ne faut pas
son émouvoir que ça peut choquer mais
c'est aussi le signe que le devoir de
mémoire que le travail de mémoire en
Allemagne a fonctionné parce que
personne n'a envie de découvrir que
était plus ou moins nazis voilà alors
évidemment en France
j'invite chacun à se poser la question
est-ce qu'on sait inquiéter de savoir si
papy et mamie avaient collaboré avec les
Allemands je pense que la question c'est
aussi beaucoup moins posée en France
généralement il y a beaucoup de
témoignages de d'enfants de
collaborateurs quand même oui oui bien
sûr moi je travaille sur sur les
écrivains qui se sont descendants de
cette mémoire et qui écrivent en ont
témoins j'insiste beaucoup sur cette
notion de non témoin parce que il y a
cette peur de la fiction la peur que
l'écrivain va s'emparer forcément mal de
ce sujet il faut avoir forcément mentir
pour plaire au plus grand nombre et
quand on regarde la littérature
contemporaine sur le choix on s'aperçoit
qu'au contraire il y a plutôt le
contraire qui se passe des écrivains qui
trouvent des moyens plus ou moins
ingénieux pour dire vous savez moi j'y
étais pas en fait il y a des témoignages
qui existent ce que je fais moi c'est
autre chose je raconte en un témoin donc
comment cette ce statut de nos témoin se
traduit en littérature
une exposition pendant pour pour 30 ans
mais qui durable plus longtemps que
jusqu'en décembre qui a commencé à la
semaine dernière et suivre de là
tourne cette exposition on regarde et
puis après on dirait un petit mot avec
Clément quand même
à l'université de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines le laboratoire
d'histoire fête ses 30 ans et pour
l'occasion des étudiants ont réalisé une
exposition sur les affiches à travers
l'histoire contemporaine alors
l'exposition elle parle des affiches et
de l'affichage alors il y a des affiches
sur le 19e siècle il y a des affiches de
l'entre-deux-guerres du Parti communiste
et ici derrière moi il y a des affiches
des films soviétiques sortis entre 1986
et 1991 varié les affiches des peignes
toute une série de mutations sociales
culturelle et économiques l'exposition
s'intéresse à la politique à la guerre
ou à d'autres institutions comme le
cinéma mon travail porté plus
précisément sur ses affiches de film
soviétique je montre comment les la fin
de la censure qui a organisé par
Gorbatchev en 1986 fait évoluer les
affiches aussi bien que les films donc
les affiches sont des historique
intéressante pour l’historien ce qui est
passionnant c'est que c'est un master
recherche donc on est
encadré par des professeurs mais en même
temps on a beaucoup de liberté pour
choisir notre sujet de recherche
l'exposition aura lieu jusqu'au 2
décembre et un colloque sur les
nouvelles perspectives de l'histoire
culturelle se tiendra les 24 et 25
novembre
alors
Maxime nous rejoindre parce qu'il était
très discret
vous êtes chargés des ressources
documentaires au Centre d'histoire et
créateur de l'exposition alors justement
d'une exposition en lien avec avec
Saint-Quentin c'est ça alors vous
évoquez peut-être le l'exposition La
Grande accélération et à la grande
accélération
qui sera effectivement exposition
artistique qui sera accessible pendant
les deux journées du colloque et une
exposition d'affiches dont on vient de
voir une vidéo ou c'est surtout ma
collègue le rapprocher qui a
effectivement beaucoup travaillé avec
avec les étudiants d'accord
Clément verger
est-ce que
ce sujet que vous êtes en train de
travailler ça vous oblige à voyager donc
un petit peu alors j'essaye les temps
modernes me font réfléchir aussi un peu
mon bilan carbone mais
mais disons que j'essaie de faire un
compromis donc récemment à cette année
j'étais à Hawaii donc ça ça fait
forcément un peu de distance et la photo
utilisée pour la fiche a été fait sur
l'île de Norfolk qui est une petite île
entre la Nouvelle-Zélande et la
Nouvelle-Calédonie et où je suis allé au
Kook a voyagé lors de son deuxième
voyage et a fait la découverte d'un
arbre qui s'appelle le peintre sur
lequel j'ai dédié dans un sens voilà un
chapitre demain de mon projet bah bravo
alors je m'appelle donc le le colloque
c'est 24h25 novembre
c'est donc à l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin
je remercie Caroline moi dans l'heure
qui vous a c'est de la place pour
quelques minutes de vous viendrez plus
longtemps la prochaine fois
merci infiniment alors merci Claude au
moins attendu merci
Aurélie Bachelet merci
Clément verger et merci Maxime un petit
et c'est aussi Caroline moine qui est
juste là et bravo pour ce voilà pour ces
30 ans merci à vous
à très vite pour une un nouveau PAF
[Musique]